You know what I did?
I went and watched the first season of "Golden Girls"
in honor of Betty White.
Aw, that's a great idea.
And it's so funny 'cause, you know,
we're talking about "Sex and the City",
and I was kind of more that age
as those girls were growing up,
and it was so informative to all of us,
but when I was a kid,
I didn't relate to "The Golden Girls" as much.
I liked it as much as a lot of people liked it,
sort of for that kitsch and friendship factor,
but now I'm watching it,
and I'm like, oh yeah, these are my problems.
I'm nearing 50.
Right.
And then you know that,
I think it's Bea Arthur is like 50,
and it's like, she's ready to hang it up,
and I'm like, wait, what?
What? You are not hanging anything up.
No, I'm not.
I'm most certainly not.
No, you're not.
(audience applauding)
It's always funny, but now it's like,
when you get it, you get it.
You know, 'cause we're there.
'Cause we're golden.
We're golden, girl.
We are golden.
What's next, Rossy?
Well, we got some
big super hero movie news.
Variety reports that Michael Keaton,
remember he played Batman.
Oh, I'll never forget.
Well, he's getting back in the bat suit
for an upcoming HBO Max movie called "Batgirl".
He's staring alongside Leslie Grace from "In The Heights".
He was in Tim Burton's Batman, remember, in 1989,
and then "Batman Returns" in 1992.
I think, maybe, he was my favorite Batman,
because I went to the movie theater,
my grandma got me a ticket, and I got a lunchbox,
and the whole thing.
Did she whip you
with a Red Vine?
How dare you.
But I did have like a little crush,
not like that kind of crush, but a crush on Kim Basinger.
It was like, I wanted to comb her hair.
That was not the cast member at all.
I thought you were gonna be crushing on, Rossy.
Yeah, well I'm, you know, I'm very layered.
I'm like an onion, just peel me,
but I really wanted to just,
I wanted to play with her hair and French braid it,
and then, go out to drink.
Vicki Vale?
Vicki Vale!
Was that her name? Yes!
Vicki Vale. Uh huh.
Gosh, there's some really great Batmans.
I was in a Batman.
(audience cheering)
I was.
Wait, wait, wait.
What?
Yeah.
What were you in?
"Batman Forever", which was Val Kilmer.
Who did you play?
And I played Sugar,
to Debi Mazar's Spice,
and we started off as Tommy Lee Jones' bad girls,
but then we switched teams,
and she stays with Tommy Lee Jones,
and I go off with Jim Carrey.
Do you know that
I think you're the coolest person I've ever met?
You can just sort of like drop in like,
"Oh yeah, I was in a Batman movie. Remember that?"
I was just hanging out, wearing lingerie.
My costume was lingerie.
Really?
Yeah.
Do you still have it?
No, no.
(Ross laughing)
I see lingerie now and I'm like, "Hell no."
White granny panties for the win.
(Drew laughing)
(audience applauding)
Granny panties, that'll come in handy
on "The Golden Girls".
Okay, well guess what our next story is.
We have got the latest winter fashion trend on social media.
You're not gonna believe this.
It's the balaclava. That's right.
Remember what used to terrify us if we saw it?
Kinda like the Scream mask.
Yeah, the balaclava
that was like
What is that?
It's like a skier's mask.
Oh, like a ski-
Burglar's mask.
Oh, yeah okay.
Those freak me out.
I can't believe this is trending,
because I just ordered one on Amazon a week ago.
For real?
Yes.
So it turns out, The Zoe Report says
it's popping up everywhere, from high-fashion runways,
to DIY versions on TikTok,
and the balaclava is actually named after
a port town in Ukraine,
and when the British and Irish troops fought there in 1852,
their wives knit them full face masks
to deal with the freezing temperatures,
and we actually have some here, Rossy.
Is this true?
Yeah, we got you some.
Look how cute that is for you, flower beauty.
Oh, this is different than the balaclava I'm picturing.
This is like a hoodie.
Oh my God. This is the cutest thing.
(audience cheering)
I like it. Can I try this one?
Hold on, I wanna get in this.
That's really cute on you.
I mean,
this just looks like something that came out of my closet.
Are you kidding? Oh no!
This is you,
through and through.
I look like Grey Gardens.
(Drew laughing)
(audience applauding)
Truth News, Edie Beale edition.
Let me try that on.
Which, this one?
I ordered one that like fully covers my face.
This one, look, this looks like Roseanne's couch.
Right, it totally does!
See, I want this.
Yeah, this is what you're looking for, right?
If there's one thing society has allowed us to do,
It's like cover up and be more mysterious.
Can I-
(audience applauding)
They should make a hybrid mask one of these.
Yeah, this is not doing anything for me right now.
And I will echo you.
That's not doing anything for you right now.
Oh my god, I do look like Edie Beale again!
You do!
(Ross laughing)
Well, in that case, I should say, we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)